Hi, Steve Kaufmann here again,
and today I'm going to talk about
whether pitch accent is important
in learning languages like Japanese.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
So, first of all, I'm back home.
All right.
Uh, I was in Palm Springs for six weeks.
I went there for a variety of reasons.
First of all, our house needed,
our house down there needed
some work to be done on it.
Uh, also, we were doing some
work here, so it was very messy,
drywall dust and so forth.
So we went down there and we also
got our second dose of the vaccine.
And then Friday night we came back
home and I'll go, I'll explain that
a little bit later, but pitch accent.
So there's quite a debate about pitch
accent, particularly in Japanese.
And I will post the link in the
description box to a person who speaks
flawless Japanese, like a Japanese person.
And he is a proponent of
studying pitch accent.
His name is Dogan, and I will also show
you a link to a video by another person
whose name escapes me, who says that
pitch accent is not worth worrying about.
And I will leave a third
link to a description of
pitch accent from Wikipedia.
So pitch accent is, uh, and it
doesn't just exist in Japanese.
It's the idea that in languages
we have varying intonation.
All right.
Intonation, that's not necessarily
tied to the meaning of a word.
So.
In Chinese, if you say a Chinese
word with the wrong tone, it's
a different meaning altogether.
And people can be confused or
have difficulty understanding
you if you use the wrong tones.
That is not the case in Japanese.
Other, uh, languages, which
according to Wikipedia have this,
uh, pitch accent include Swedish,
Turkish, Persian, Western Basque.
Okay, just Western  Basque.
Uh, and I can't remember how...
ancient Greek a number of languages that,
um, according to them, Serbo-Croation
have this pitch accent issue.
Now, let me say upfront that I lived in
Japan for nine years, I spoke Japanese,
Japanese and still do quite comfortably.
I met a lot of foreigners
who spoke Japanese very well.
No one that I was aware of had
ever heard of pitch accent.
So probably it exists.
Maybe it's something that some people want
to spend time on, but it is not necessary.
It is not necessary.
It's not a unnecessary part of learning
the language, of communicating.
It's certainly not necessary in so
far as comprehension is concerned.
Um, in Chinese, on the other hand, if you
speak Chinese with very bad tones, people
may have difficulty understanding you.
And in any case, it sounds quite bad.
It sounds as if you don't speak the
language very well, you would have
to get those tones up to about 70,
80% accuracy to be taken seriously.
In Japanese, that is not the case.
I never pay any attention to pitch accent.
I just consider, whatever it pitch accent
is and I still don't understand it, it's
part of imitating the way people speak.
Every language has its own intonation.
Even within Japan, the intonation
in the Kansai and the Osaka area
is different from the intonation.
In, um, you know, the Northeast
and Tohoku area and the same
is true for every language.
I mean, if you've ever heard a French
Canadian, the Quebecois speak French,
their intonation is very different
from the intonation in Paris,
which is different from the
intonation in Southern France.
Uh, if you've ever heard a Swiss
person speak, even English very often,
they'll have their Swiss intonation.
And I can only imagine that
their Hochdeutsch, their
standard German also sounds
quite different from the intonation
of a, of an Austrian or a
Bavarian or someone from Hamburg.
So the idea that there is
intonation in a language, I mean,
we have intonation in English.
I remember when I, one of the reasons
why I decided to learn Cantonese was
that having learned Mandarin with
its four tones and having all these
Cantonese people scare you off saying
cantonese is the most difficult
language because it has nine tones.
And I said, geez, I mean, I had enough
trouble learning four tones, nine tones
is just too difficult, but I found
this book written by a Chinese person,
Cantonese speaker, who, first of all said,
you only need six tones for Cantonese.
And second of all, pointed out that
we have tones in English and you
can hear me hear me in my English.
I also have tones.
So, is it worthwhile, you know,
going into great detail, classifying?
I mean, Persian is described
or Turkish as a tonal language.
I just listened to it
and try to imitate it.
Um, I think I do.
Okay.
I don't have enough vocabulary
in those languages to speak them
well, but it's not my lack of
emphasis on pitch accent
that's holding me back.
Uh, by the way, just to digress, so my
wife and I head back home to Canada, uh,
some trepidation about what's going to
happen at the border because actually
the government heavily discourages you
from traveling outside the country.
And if you fly into a major airport, you
have to quarantine in a hotel that the
government dictates and you pay for it.
While waiting for your first test results
to come back could be two or three days.
We didn't want to do that.
So we flew from Palm Springs
to Bellingham, which is 20
minutes from the border.
The luggage took a while to come out.
So it was getting later and later
we had trouble getting an Uber.
We couldn't get an Uber.
We finally got a Lyft driver
to come to the airport.
He drove us to the border.
Now it's dark.
It's close to 10 o'clock.
We're dropped off at the Peace Arch Park.
We don't know where to go.
We wander around in the park.
Finally found a sort of a sidewalk,
followed it, got to a road.
Walked for about a mile, pulling my
luggage until we got to the border.
And there, there, there's a very
serious looking sign there with a
big stop sign stop until you are
"motioned forward by an agent".
Okay.
I stop.
So we waited and waited and waited cars
every so often a car would come back and
the customs official would come along.
Customs official would deal with the car.
I thought, how are they ever
going to pay attention to us?
So finally they came and, um,
basically I had registered on a
government app or downloaded an app.
So I had already sent them
ahead all our information.
So it went very, very smoothly.
They knew who we were, uh, asked us a
few questions and then told us that we
would have to quarantine for 14 days.
And that the penalty for breaking
quarantine could be as high as a
million dollars or three years in jail.
I don't think they'd ever do that, but
that's kind of to scare you, right?
And then they said, you're lucky because
the self-testing tent hasn't closed yet.
So go off to the tent there and the
nurse, there will show you how to
self test, because we're going to
have to self test again in seven days.
So we went ahead, and there were two or
three different nurses that couldn't have
been kinder, more helpful, more pleasant.
Took us through our paces, registered
us on a website where we have to report.
Then our second test, did
the test in our nostrils.
One 15 seconds in each nostril, put it
in this little container, send it off.
We're going to have to do
the same seven days later.
Then we went out to find an Uber, uh,
walked a ways and then call the Uber.
Our Uber driver got lost.
ENded up actually having, I think he
went across into the United States.
He then told us that the border
guards had told him that, uh, you
know, he had to prove that he was
an Uber driver, so he wouldn't
have to quarantine on his way back.
Anyway, he was an African immigrant.
So I was able to speak some
Farsi with him in the car.
I have no idea what pitch accent he
had and I think it makes no difference.
Just a brief aside, I think that the
only way we're getting through this,
uh, COVID epidemic is through vaccines.
Anybody who is not willing to get
a vaccine is simply a part of the
problem, not a part of the solution.
And the same was true with
masking before we were vaccinated.
That was the only way we could
keep a lid on the pandemic.
I just don't understand people who
in the name of some kind of freedom,
refuse to cooperate with everybody else
in trying to basically help the whole
of society get through this thing.
Anyway, that's, as an aside...
I have the freedom to drive through
a red light, it's the same idea.
Anyway, getting back to pitch accent.
So.
I think all these languages
probably have pitch accent.
I think there is a great tendency,
it's fine for linguists academic link
with, to study different qualities
of languages and categorize them.
And this is subject-verb-object, and
this is subject-object-verb, and this
belongs to this other group and it
doesn't matter for the language learner.
We simply have to imitate what we hear.
We have to get used to the pattern
of the language and, um, In my
Swedish, there are tones in Swedish.
I like to Imitate ...you imitate it.
Yeah, the same is true in Japanese.
And if I spend a lot of time with
people from Osaka, uh, I end up
with more of an Osaka accent.
Um, it doesn't affect the meaning.
It's not like Chinese tones.
But it's something that, uh, again,
you know, you talk about tones that
compare, uh, compare a Brazilian to
someone from Portugal, different area,
different people, even native speaker,
they're going to have different types of
intonation and you will naturally want
to imitate the accent and the intonation.
That, that either you like the
best, or that is more useful for you
in your work or you consider more
prestigious or whatever it might be.
And I don't think, and the other thing
about pitch accent, it is possible that
if I put a lot of effort on pitch accent,
so I decided, uh, I'm not going to be, I'm
not going to allow myself to be influenced
by having spent two evenings with people
from Osaka, which inevitably makes me
speak with more of an Osaka accent.
I'm going to try to, you know,
nail down the, the sort of pitch
accent of the Japanese national
broadcast announcer NHK announcer.
So I'm gonna go whole hog
with the Dogan program.
Uh, and, but the problem is that
language is about communication.
It's not a performance sport.
No one, I I'm not, I don't care if
people tell me, well, you're Japanese
pronunciation is, sounds a bit
this way or that way I don't care.
Uh, people are comfortable
communicating with me.
I'm comfortable because I understand
what people are saying to me in Japanese.
Um, I'm not seeking perfection.
Uh, you know, it's, it's not a
performance it's it's communication.
And to that extent people who do want
to achieve the NHK announcers, uh,
intonation by all means, but to pretend
that this is important, uh, it's not as
important as increasing your vocabulary.
It's not as important as having a
good command of the language and
using words appropriately, using
words that belong together, being
able to express your thoughts.
Clearly that's far more important than
pursuing the ultimate, you know, in tones.
I ha...
I mentioned this before, I had
a Swiss banker who came in with
his sidekick from England, uh,
to try and sell something to us.
The Swiss banker had a strong
Swiss accent in his English.
But he used words so well, he expressed
himself so accurately, so elegantly
and his English sidekick, maybe he
wasn't that well educated, he didn't
use the English language as well,
but he spoke with a native accent.
So if you want to pursue pitch
accent by all means do so.
But in my opinion, it's not
that important and I certainly
pay no attention to it anyway.
Uh, and I'm going to leave a couple
of videos here to follow up on
the subject of pronunciation and
seeking to be perfect and so forth.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.